it's a pleasure to be here
i'm gonna talk to you about
how scarcity imposes demand on our
cognitive capacity
in other words on how the psychology
that comes from
not having enough demands attention and
cognitive capacity and leaves us
with less mind for other things i want
to include
um i'm going to quickly mentioned
scarcity of money certainly poverty
scarcity of time scarcity of calories if
you're dieting
water etc and the argument is going to
be then when
you don't have enough of something it
captures your attention it captures
your mental capacity and leaves you with
less now you'll see later how all this
connects actually very nicely
with the talks we had before we all know
that
attention is limited one of the things
that's interesting is that we fail to
appreciate
the extent to which it's limited many of
you may have seen
recent research on using cell phone and
cars we all know it's not so good it's a
disaster
it's you know basically compares to
being legally drunk but u.s standards
this is a classroom in new haven it's a
lovely study that was done
where they noticed that the fifth
graders in this class randomly assigned
happened to find themselves either on
the quiet side of the school
or on the other side of the school where
trains were going by and so when you sit
in the class
and this train goes by there should be a
sound if you could hear it
that has an enormous distraction on kids
attentional capacity
and what they found is that the kids
near the train tracks were one year
in academic performance behind their
friends on the other side of the school
at fifth grade they then install
installed uh soundproofing and a couple
years later they
were matched again so this is just a
passing train with an enormous impact
and the point is that these are trains
in the external world
you don't need them to be an external
world imagine yourself in an office
very quiet no distractions except you're
worried about
paying rent or a child who is sick
or anything else those internal trains
are gonna have an impact that could
compare in terms of the attentional
distraction and the cognitive capacity
to having destructions on the outside
an amazing study that was done in the
40s had to do with when the allied
forces realized
they were about to inherit a lot of
hungry people in europe and they had no
idea how to feed them
feeding hungry people is a is a
non-trivial task
a famous researcher into nutrition in
minnesota conducted a series of studies
these are
conscientious objectors who since
they're objecting to the good war
were very eager to volunteer to these
studies these are capable young men who
volunteer to starve
not to death but to immense discomfort
and
when you look at the descriptions of
what happens you know there's the
obvious physical stuff they
they're too tired to keep their hands up
to wash their hair
they need pillows to sit down because
their butts are too naked
but the amazing stuff also is the
psychological these are young talented
men
who spend their entire time planning to
open restaurants
reading recipes comparing prices of
foods in different stores in newspapers
that's all they're thinking about it's
taking all their cognitive capacity
it's about food at some point the the
researchers described decide to distract
them by showing them some films
and you these guys describe the films
and they couldn't care less about the
love scenes they want to see the meals
and what's important here is this is not
something they're choosing to do in a
sense they'd rather do something else
it just imposes itself on their minds
and it's very hard to avoid
so the notion is that cognitive capacity
which is a very limited resource
is captured by when you don't have
enough of something
and you basically find yourself
automatically paying
a lot of mind to that thing you don't
have
now um a footnote uh if this works well
you should have these annoying blinks on
the screen if it was darker in here
would be very annoying
these blinks that you're seeing last 350
milliseconds
that's how long you've get darkness
every time you blink
you blink approximately 15 times a
minute during the 12 hours of your wake
every day you get one hour
of nothing but dark input into your eyes
which you have never seen
that's to say that your brain is doing
amazing stuff
to which you have no introspective
access and that's sort of important
because we walk around with this amazing
machine and we think we know what it's
doing
you know we know roughly that we know
what our liver is doing you know unless
you're a physician
and so basically a lot of the behavioral
research and i'm saying this because
it's very important when you get
behavioral research not to do the yeah
does it feel right to me or not
the argument is a lot of what we
discover in behavioral research is about
a mechanism that's
magnificently sophisticated that's
behind the eyes and between the ears to
which you have very little access
i want to talk about particularly about
poverty and a little bit about time but
again the notion is
that scarcity in food friends water
will capture your attention in this way
and be very profound
nice studies have been shown for example
that it's top of mind so you get
subjects into a laboratory who have been
asked not to drink for four hours
they're not very thirsty half of them
randomly assigned get water
the other half get pretzels not a good
idea when you're thirsty
then they sit in front of a computer and
have to identify words these are words
that are flashing roughly as long as you
had the blank it's 400 milliseconds
and you have to decide yes it's a word
or not it's a word and what you find is
when you get words that are related to
thirst
those who have had pretzels identify
these words much faster
than those who've had water if you
compare the performance to neutral words
they're identical
again this is not this is pre-decisional
it's way too fast
it's literally showing that the words
that are related to first have higher
semantic activation they're literally
top of mind they're there to be
tickled then anything happens that's
relevant as opposed to other words
and what the notion is that when it's
top of mind loneliness for example
there's nice
research showing it's kind of a sad
research but it's very compelling
when you're very lonely and loneliness
is mentioned
or brought up you function less well
it's distracting
so the the sort of tragic impact that
loneliness has
is that people are socially as capable
as anybody else
when they think about loneliness such as
for example when you're interacting with
somebody what really matters to you do
well
that's when you do the least well
because you have cognitive capacity
taken by the concerns related to
loneliness
dieting and cinnabons very similar uh
here is a study we did in california
these are
this is a study we've done with dieters
and non-dieters
we have them play fun word searches you
see these are words where the odd number
words are food related cake doughnut
sweets
and the even number words are neutral
there's two conditions that get either
this one or they get
another condition where now the
food-related words have been replaced by
other
irrelevant neutral words we're gonna
have the dieters look and the
non-dieters look for these
to find all these words and what i'm
going to do now is look at how long it
takes them to find
the neutral words the words that are
common to both so basically i'm asking
how long does it take you to find the
word cloud
when it's preceded by a doughnut or when
it's preceded by a picture
and what you see is that the
non-doubters it makes no
significant difference the dieters take
twice as long to find
cloud having just seen a doughnut than
having just seen a neutral word
it literally interferes with what you do
next
so it's top of mind and when it's
triggered it sits there and it lingers
and it takes cognitive capacity
for what else you want to do
financial poverty is the ultimate of all
scarcities we talk about a lot of other
scarcities it's important to keep in
mind
this is one that's non-discretionary
i'll talk briefly about the busy you
know when you're very busy you don't
have time we all talk about how busy we
are
don't tell anybody but between us if you
stop doing what you're doing nothing
would happen
except for the few physicians in the
room but basically it's discretionary we
choose to be busy
when you're poor and we can get into
interesting discussions about you know
what it is the minimum that you need and
how that changes culturally but when you
don't have enough when you can't pay
rent when you can't put food on the
table that's not discretionary
and you can't take a break when you're a
dieter there's a really nice research on
this
and you have a very important project
this week you say you know what this
week i'll just do what i need to do i'll
go back to dieting next week
notice you can't say i'll be rich this
week i'll go back to being poor next
not available so it's a much more
chronic permanent and imposing condition
and what we did in this case is we ran
some studies in a mall in new jersey
we'll go to people in the mall ask them
to participate
they sit in front of a computer we give
them classic cognitive tests that have
been used in cognitive science for the
last 30 or 40 years
one is a test of cognitive control
divided attention of sorts so
you sit in front of a computer when you
see heart you have to quickly press the
same side
when you see flower you suppress you
have to press the opposite side you can
you can you're getting a headache right
away it's confusing it takes a lot of
attention
the other all of you have seen if you've
done an sat or gre any kind of test it's
a classic
test that's supposed to capture fluid
intelligence it's a
major component of the iq test basically
which shape fits best in a missing space
so they sit and do these tests and
while they're doing these tests we give
them financial scenarios to contemplate
your car breaks down you have to think
how you're going to take care of it
in one condition the non-menacing
condition the car is going to cost 300
to fix in the other condition the
challenging condition it's gonna cost a
thousand five hundred
as you're thinking about are you gonna
take care of the car you do these and
when you finish them you tell us how
you're gonna solve your financial
problem
okay finally we'll get people's annual
household income
and divide them by basically splitting
in half into rich and poor
okay so we know you're either rich and
poor we give you these problems either
a cheap car to take care of or an
expensive car to take care of and you do
these
cognitive control and intelligence tests
what do you get
let's look first at the rich the rich
when they contemplate the easy or the
difficult car
perform equally well in the cognitive
control like it's got
driving test the poor when they
contemplate
the easy car the one they can easily
afford look exactly like the rich
but when they're thinking about a car
that's hard to manage that's hard to
to afford they're now driving
significantly less swell the cognitive
control has diminished
let's move to iq the rich are not
impacted by what kind of car they're
fixing while they're taking these
cognitive tests
the poor when they're doing when they're
thinking about the car that's easy to
take care of
look indistinguishable from the rich but
when they're poor are worried about a
car that's
presenting a real financial challenge
they're performing here we've done this
now four different
ways replicated four times with
financial incentives
they're losing the equivalent of 13 iq
points
so these are the same people minutes ago
when the car was manageable performed
just like the rich
now that the car presents a serious
imposition takes a lot of mind
perform significantly less well on these
iq tests on this
fluid intelligence tests um
we did all the controls we could in new
jersey but these are the end of the day
different people they're
richer and less rich they've had
different education and they have
different heart rates and everything
else
the dream was could we do this within
subjects the same person it's not so
easy to get
people you know hundreds of them who are
both rich and poor but the third world
does present cases like these and this
is the best one we found
these are sugar cane harvests in outside
chennai in the fields in india
and the sugarcane is a particularly good
case because you harvest only once a
year
these are all people whose bulk of bulk
of their income is
received only once a year they're rich
after the harvest
and because they're living relatively
tight life and have a hard time
smoothing their consumption they end up
they find themselves poor
before the harvest so we run the same
people now
four months apart two months before
harvest and two months after harvest
a lot of nuances that make this very
nice because the mills
because they're over capacity they tell
the farmer when to harvest so the
harvesters for over many months we get
rid of all kinds of month effects etc
what you find essentially like in new
jersey the same people
score significantly less swell and
cognitive control and
fluid intelligence tests before harvest
when they're poor
as composed as opposed to after harvest
when they're rich
and now of course we've kept health
education everything else intact
it's literally a function of whether you
have enough or not and how much
cognitive capacity that takes from you
as you're trying to do these stupid
tests
um time i'll spend less time today on
time but
many of us many of you are time poor in
ways that are not completely different
from the way that our subjects in india
and new jersey are money poor
you have to think trade-offs you have to
borrow from today
from tomorrow to do things you haven't
had time to do today at high interest
etc um what we did here is run uh these
are princeton students nobody would
blame them for being myopic they're
highly educated they're very
sophisticated
we have them play a game classic many of
you know family feud it's a game where
they're trying to get the answers
they're very eager to do well the
performance gets translated into payoff
and we make them randomly either time
rich or time poor so you either have 50
seconds per round
or 15 seconds per round which is not
quite enough and
in some conditions you cannot borrow so
when you're out of time you have to move
to the next round
in other cases we allow you to borrow we
offer you payday loans basically
predatory lending rates you can borrow
at high
rates so every second you take now you
have two seconds less
left at the end of the game we look at
how they do
what happens uh there's two measures
there's rounds completed and points
earned
i'm not going into the details this is
what you see when there's no ability to
borrow
so when you cannot borrow notice the
rich obviously
play more rounds and get more points
because they're rich they're playing
more games
now i'm going to let you borrow now if
you run out of time if you want to you
can take more seconds
the rich notice um this should come on
at a time maybe i don't have it
the rich notice there is no impact at
all
there is high interest borrowing
available do i want to borrow i look and
i said no it's not really useful it's
not really worth it i'm not doing it
the poor same princeton students just
with less money
are dying to get this right are running
out of time are focused on what they're
doing right now the periphery gets less
mind and they borrow and they run at a
time too quickly and they score and they
leave the experiment with substantially
less money
so we're basically seeing the
sophisticated princeton students taking
payday loans
of the kind that we typically claim the
poor are doing out of lack of insight
and intelligence
it looks very much not a function of who
the person is but the context you put
them in
that makes them act poor in ways that
minutes earlier
in the mall in the fields of chennai in
this in the princeton lab
you have voted if you were just a bit
richer
implications we all need to take policy
uh uh bandwidth a lot more seriously
we have very limited mind when it's
devoted to some areas and in poverty
it's a massive one that never leaves us
alone
there is just less mind to pay attention
to other things and policymakers
typically don't think this way so
you saw phil's uh fafsa application
think about a poor person who comes for
some benefits program imagine i proposed
let's charge them 300
to join you'd say to me wait they have
no money they're coming for help
why would you charge your money well
they also don't have bandwidth
and when we charge them massive
bandwidth to attend all kinds of events
at the right hour
and fill out complicated forms and do
all the things that they exactly are
what they don't have enough of namely
bandwidth and attentional resources
were kind of doing the wrong policies so
phil's fafsa beautiful study that you
saw is one example where you basically
could
alleviate some bandwidth limitations
a lot of work has been done on
defaulting workers into retirement
savings they're supposed to expect them
to do it on their own
that has a big effect among people who
are too busy and in healthcare there's a
massive effect so this is a glow cap
a globe cap is a 12 dollar plastic
bottle that delivers your medication and
it's structured
so that if it's not open at the right
time it blips and blinks and sends you
an email
saying i haven't been opened in time and
it turns out there's some estimates in
the third world where hiv is one case
where you can't just take 60
of the time you have to take all of it
all the time some estimates that
12 below cap is having a two decade life
expectancy impact
and clearly it's the case where people
want to take it they intend to take it
but bandwidth is limited and they forget
and so if you take that more seriously
there's an enormous amount you can do
uh last thought i'll leave you just a
picture that might stay in your mind
in aviation it's become very clear very
early on that you can't train pallets
any better that's all they can do
as avionics get more complicated it's up
to you to design more sophisticated
cockpits
and the argument here is if you look at
people managing their poverty
their scarcity in different resources
it's up to us policymakers and others to
design basically
a cockpit a life that's more manageable
given severely limited resources
okay i'll stop here
you